I don't want to hurt you bro I do not
want to shoot you put it down you don't
want to end it this way
you don't want to end it this way
brother I promise you whatever happened
today it can be fixed don't pull the
trigger put it down
I Dean put it down buddy
don't do it man put it down all the way
up in the air keep walking towards me
keep walking toward me keep hadeem come
on buddy don't retreat come back this
way come toward me man come toward me my
gun is only out because I don't know
what you're gonna do when you get to
over here Imma have you listen to me I'm
gonna have you lay down on the ground
and my gun is going in my my holster I
promise you if you will walk toward me
keep your hands up hadeem keep your
hands up don't go back toward that thing
man
walk toward me with your hands up I'ma
walk you through every process please
don't pick that back up
please don't hey one one person talking
please don't pick that back up I got you
I got you dog I'm telling you I got you
listen to how this will go if you'll
walk out to me with your hands up in the
air when you get to about right here
I'ma have you lay down on the ground my
gun is going in the holster bet that
it's going in the hole sir
don't pick it up again
don't do it buddy
you made you made such a good choice
putting it down bro just leave it on the
ground hadeem walk all the way out all
the way keep coming keep coming to me
keep coming to me keep coming I'm gonna
tell you when to stop keep coming to me
bud
keep coming keep coming come on you're
good bro you're good
you're good keep walking toward me
hadeem don't do it Bud yeah
keep on keep him keep on keep them keep
coming toward me keep coming toward me
the pavement's gonna be hot what I'm
happy to do is I'm gonna have you lay
down in the grass lay down on the grass
lay down in the grass lay down in the
grass lay down in the grass watch lay
all the way down my gun is going in it's
holster somebody's got cover
all right hey I was I was all the way
down if we ex-filled from that house
deeper
horsey who did you shoot
Aviation on channel 10 who'd you shoot
look at me my eyeballs
I don't have a clue what just happened
in there
thank you